New Times bestselling author James clear
says you can fight the morning blues
with an effective morning and a.m.
routine his latest book is and atomic
habits an easy and proven way to build
good habits and break bad ones
James cleared swear that we have guests
come on so soon but we can't stop
talking about your last appearance yes
what makes for an effective morning
routine and can it start at 40 a.m. you
know there is no one morning routine
right that like successful people follow
it could involve meditation it could
involve exercise it could involve
writing down your to-do list and
prioritizing your tasks for the day
there's no one single thing that people
do but I think that if you look at
people who set their day up for success
one thing that they do have no matter
whether it's at home or at work is some
kind of sacred space to prioritize the
day to think about what do I need to get
done today what's going to set this day
or for success and they have that time
kind of carved out and how long do you
need to set aside well for me my morning
routine is incredibly fast so you know I
wake up take a shower get a glass of
water and then I prioritize and get
started on the first task so I'm done
and like in to work within 15 minutes
but for other people they find that they
want a little more time to ease into the
day so there's no single amount of time
so bathing is important to you yes it is
you and eat the Frog kind of person do
your hardest test first or do you
prioritize to later in the day so it's
strangest say both but you're the whole
idea behind eat the Frog is you take the
very most difficult thing you work on
that first right but I think there's
also value in gaining momentum as soon
as you wake up and so I think something
as simple as making your bed as soon as
you wake up in the morning get some kind
of like positive flow moving into the
day and so I like to have something like
that make the bed to get things moving
in the right direction and then start
working on the mostess and I've heard
you say that a good morning actually
starts the night before when I hear you
say that I go what you talking about
Willis
I don't get that well a good morning
starts the night before because often
and this is especially true for parents
right like you can have the best idea in
the world for your morning routine but
your four-year-old doesn't care they'll
come in and derail everything and so for
many families getting out the door feels
like this race just to get to school or
get things going in the morning
and if you can prioritize some of those
things the night before or whether it's
coming up with your to-do list the
for the next day or you know making
lunches for the kids at school things
like that the more that you can get done
the night before the more you can set
yourself up for success and then the
second part of that is sleep you know
you can't it doesn't matter what your
morning routine is you can't cheat the
fact that you don't have enough sleep if
that's when you wake up and so but by
giving to get to bed at a normal hour
and having a good power-down routine you
set yourself up
seems like technology to James just
disrupts morning routines oh absolutely
you know I think this is especially true
for Millennials and people in the
younger generation that we all use our
phones as our alarms and so you wake up
you turn your alarm off and then rather
than getting out of bed you kind of lay
there and just start to scroll and it's
like well I don't quite want to get up
yet and then before you know it 10 15 20
minutes of passage I'm gonna be late and
so I think one solution to that is to
charge your phone in another room rather
than keeping it next to you we are
almost out of time - speaking of time
but it's great to have you back on some
great chips thank you